no way i'm not gonna make it right coach
they always told me to follow my dreams
maybe that's something that they say to
a lot of kids
push-ups i'm too tired you're the number
one player in the area code what do you
think the haters want my baby to be
tired
my son needs a coach like you he'll take
your team from good to oh my god i don't
coach high school kids all my kids 14
years jace turned 14 yesterday
these programs are where the best talent
is getting their start these are future
nba stars
[Applause]
[Music]
no way i'm not gonna make it right coach
i guess i've been worried that
everything i want could be slipping away
i dropped in the rankings from one to
four so clap back on the court you gotta
reclaim that crown can't afford to lose
coach not you not me your program is
barely holding on financially you're
gonna screw things up like you always do
my father would tell me that i had to
learn what it is to lose before i learn
what it is to win
i didn't do nowhere else he is an eighth
grade honest student this feeling you
have right now that fire
use it
[Music]
if you want to get to nationals you're
gonna have to win out the tournament no
more losses
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes other things in life feel more
important than basketball you aren't
just my teammates anymore y'all are my
brothers no doubt
people are gonna want you to stand for
many things more than anything
a team stands for each other
[Music]
you walk off with swagger
[Music]
you